à 71 ans claudette leblanc dirige d'une
main de fer le restaurant chez claudette
cela fait 35 ans qu'elle est installée
ici et son commerce a bien évolué j'ai
rajouté le banquier le restaurant j'ai
rajouté la poste
j'ai rajouté le tabac j'ai rajouté les
je m'appuie c'est peut-être pas tout
puisqu'il y avait bar essence et gaz
quentin a pris c'est tout autant de
services indispensables dans une commune
loin de tout le bureau de poste le plus
proche se trouve dans le village voisin
à plus de 10 km la station-service à
bourges soit près d'une demi-heure en
voiture
alors même si claudette soit prendre sa
retraite elle recule la date de son
départ s'il se réfère ne la porte n'est
plus rien il ya plus de postes et puis
le bar n'est plus de décence
et puis demain y'a plus rien je suis le
pilier d'ici
on verra
parce que senna gagne et on verra s'il
ya plus à ben je sais pas je sais pas
comment on va faire
à part aller à bourges ou des fois les
airs pour avoir du gazole ça peut pas
quoi mais l'habitant faut que ça vive
voilà il ya des enfants partout et les
nouveaux pavillons qui se construisent
tout ce soit yvan bressy le maire se dit
prêt à racheter les murs sous condition
qu'il y ait un repreneur
mais selon lui le problème est plus
office
c'est aussi l'état qu'ils ne se
désengage un peu on ne peut pas non plus
on peut essayer de faire au maximum et
on peut pas tout faire sans sans aide
non la poste tomber les commerces se
désengage le problème des commerces et
qui a plus de plus d'offres que de
demandes
c'est aussi un grand tenir un commerce
claudette a même mis son commerce sur le
bon coin pour multiplier ses chances
bressy reste le symbole d'une france
fracture est abandonnée par les
commerces et les services publics